veiled in a light mist what happens at
sea
is out of sight and out of mind but
greenpeace is on a mission to expose
destructive fishing practices
in british waters for six months its
boats will patrol
ostensibly protected areas off the south
coast
looking for super trawlers with nets a
mile long
that scoop up everything in the way a
couple of miles offshore we found david
in his small boat he can't compete
there's barely any fish left
the nets i use now for mackerel they're
300 yards long is to use 100 yards
put it in profit now i've got a day's
work and when i kneel
i put the net in three times yesterday
13 fish
operation ocean witness is also looking
for evidence of this
the gouged almost lifeless devastation
left by trawlers
dragging heavy fishing gear along the
bottom right now the uk
government stands up on the world stage
and claims to be a leader in ocean
protection because it's got
all of these marine protected areas
surrounding its coastline
however inside these protected areas
you're still allowed to do
pretty much whatever you like so we're
seeing bottom twirling that's fishing
where you're
dragging nets along the bottom we're
seeing dredging we're seeing
all kinds of destructive fishing that is
completely unsustainable
the uk has set aside 64 offshore areas
that on paper
protect habitats like reefs and corals
but in 62 of them trawlers last year
dragged heavy fishing gear along the
bottom
for a total of 68 000 hours
that's a rise of 10 percent from 2019
greenpeace wants the practice banned in
conservation areas
the ocean quickly bounces back once is
given proper protection
research suggests that within five years
there are so many fish that they spill
out into surrounding areas
where fishing boats can still operate
it's a win-win
for both the environment and the
industry
the government is considering plans to
ban trawlers from towing fishing gear
along the bottom of
four conservation zones greenpeace says
it's nowhere near enough
thirty percent of the ocean needs
meaningful protection
to sustain marine life and keep fish
on the menu thomas more sky news in new
haven